now that Michael Cohen has pleaded
guilty to eight counts including to
campaign finance violations all sorts of
new information is coming out of the
woodwork one part I told you about
yesterday already is that Cohen claims
according to his lawyer Lanny Davis then
he didn't just decide on his own to make
these hush money payments which were
against the law too stormy Daniels into
Karen McDougal
Cohen claims that Trump specifically
directed him to do that that is a direct
implication as I told you earlier of
Trump in crimes that Michael Cohen has
already pleaded guilty to a new
revelation and it's a big one is that
Michael Cohen made a previously
unreported payment of 50 grand here we
go now to a tech company in connection
with Donald Trump's 2016 presidential
campaign the document that has been
obtained so far doesn't name the tech
company and it also doesn't explain what
exactly the company did for Donald
Trump's campaign for the $50,000 but why
is this notable there's a few reasons
first of all Cohen paying a tech company
for something related to Trump's
campaign tells us that Cohen was doing
more for the campaign than we had been
led to believe we had been led to
believe that Cohen was effectively not
involved in the campaign if he's paying
tech companies for campaign related
services that already contradicts the
notion that he wasn't involved number
two
Cohen has already ready pleaded guilty
to campaign finance crimes so now any
financial stuff that we learned Cohen
was involved in related to the Trump
campaign we're going to want to look at
very closely and that gets us to the
third layer of sketchiness which is that
Michael Cohen paid the 50 grand and then
the idea is he gets reimbursed by the
campaign if the money was spent for
something that's campaign related
normally as the court documents show
Cohen would present the Trump
Organization with invoices for the
payments he made makes perfect sense
you're Michael Cohen you're doing
something for the campaign you spend 50
grand and then you get reimbursed for
the 50 grand for this particular $50,000
payment to this tech company which we
have not yet even identified Cohen
didn't present an invoice
he wrote 50 grand on top of another
document that is how Michael Cohen asked
to be repaid the 50 grand he just
scratched in writing $50,000 on top of a
different document the Trump
Organization was asked about this
they have had said no comment the Trump
campaign was asked about this they are
saying no comment the Trump White House
was asked about this they are saying no
comment we do not know what the $50,000
was for and there are some obvious
things that our viewers are emailing me
and saying you know David this 50 grand
is obviously connected to Russian cyber
crimes we don't know I'm not going to
assert that without evidence or another
email David this 50 grand is obviously
money that was paid to hack Hillary's
emails I just don't think that's the way
it would be done if the Trump campaign
was directing the hacking of him
Hillary's emails until we have more
evidence we don't know but what we can
say Pat is that there's a lot of money
floating around here connected to Cohen
and connected to the 2016 campaign we
were told that he wasn't really involved
in the campaign and he's already pleaded
guilty to crimes involving campaign
finance so it's a bad situation I just
had a hard time believing that this
payment would be for something like
canvassing or collecting voter data I
think that kind of stuff would be left
the Trump campaigns volunteers or
lower-level staffers oh yeah Michael
Cohen do that if Michael Cohen was
involved in payment he would get a
proper invoice for that he wouldn't just
write 50 grand on a piece of paper and
hand it to somebody to give him the
money what I do want to call your
attention to and and I know there are
people who are gonna lose their minds
okay so put on your seat belts page 34
of the Christopher steel dossier also
known as the Trump Russia dossier or the
dodgy dossier if you want to quote
Carter page who was on the show recently
just to be thorough here's what page 34
of the dossier says Michael Cohen was up
to Trump's representative Cohen
accompanied to Prague in August
September 2016 by three colleagues for
secret discussions with Kremlin
representatives and associated operators
/ hackers and here is the key line
agenda included how to process deniable
cash
two operatives contingency plans for
covering up operations and action in
event of a Clinton victory deniable cash
payments to hackers and Michael Cohen's
attorney lanny davis said on MSNBC two
nights ago that cohen has knowledge of
connections between the Trump campaign
and Russian hackers I'm not saying
that's what this 50 grand is related to
but there are a lot of very strange
coincidences happening here send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
I do look forward to hearing from you
today's show is made possible in part by
news voice comm slash Pakman we have
talked on this program for a year after
year after year how American media is
controlled by just a small handful
really of huge corporations and the
problem with having media conglomerates
among others is that you get filter
bubbles you get echo chambers and this
is something I talk about on the program
a lot there's a new media company that's
come up with an interesting response to
this problem it's called news voice and
what it is is a website and app for both
iOS and Android which gives you a
personalized news feed by aggregating a
mix of mainstream media sources along
with international sources and
independent media sources importantly so
any story you look at you will get
multiple sources you can upvote stories
you think are important so that more
people will see them you can add a story
to the site you can add a source that's
missing for a particular story and the
idea is for it to be completely open and
democratized as a source of news and you
can get every side of every story check
out the app which you can download for
free if you go to news voice calm slash
Pakman if you're watching this on
YouTube
simply click the link below the video